okay i'm in my condo i'm on my way
outside it's uh jason's birthday
tomorrow but i'm not gonna see him
tomorrow so i plan some fun things to do
today so i'm gonna surprise him and uh
take you guys on the journey and we'll
see what happens
i asked jason to meet me at eleven
o'clock at the corner of young and
shepherd the heart
of end city and it is now 10
57 so we're gonna go out and find him
that's actually him there in the hat he
doesn't know i'm behind him
maybe i'll go try to steal his bag
that was amazing dude
happy birthday man we're gonna celebrate
some birthday love
i love it i'm excited i was uh i wanted
to meet the southwest corner let me zoom
in over here
there it is young and shepherd and city
okay you hungry yeah we're gonna go eat
all right let's go i love it let's take
a tour of end city
and city represent look they got all
kinds of new buildings and developments
oh yeah oh yeah i bet those are gonna be
new businesses whole foods is opening up
like this week see
what they should open up today for my
birthday how dare they
how you feeling man i feel like you're
rocking it we got the j
rise documentary here a city builder
spread spread some uh spread some
some wisdom drop some wisdom on youtube
nation here
on the spot on the spot on the spot
jason
i'm i'm struggling to build my empire yo
what do i do
what do i do son you wake up and
celebrate like we're doing today
seriously what you uh your interview
with the
zooka interview you were talking about
mental mindset
and you wanna get underlies everything
it does
so you gotta wake up and celebrate
celebrate something celebrate oxygen
celebrate
that you have ground like something
celebrate what celebrate what
something man anything what was the
brown what'd you say that you have
ground oh that you have ground that you
have ground
i'd like to build on or just sit on like
got it nobody
you didn't have to earn that right
that's all right
and now i didn't have to earn this
birthday meeting but it's coming right
to me
we got it i like the hat the rocking the
hat
40 years of history in this hat what's
the hat what's the story
link random order gave me this hat
but it originally came from his father
all right
crashing it down this is a royal stetson
i feel like a uh
royal right i got the crown kenzo ramen
one of my favorite spots in ant city to
go have some lunch
and we're gonna celebrate jason's
birthday and we go
okay so i have a usual favorite that we
can order two of
if you want or you can rock into the
menu and do it yeah no no i i'm open to
recommendations okay okay two of my
favorites
two of my favorites coming up i'm gonna
let me find it it's the it's the
let me look at it here let me make sure
i got the right thing going on here
where are we going it's the uh chicken
katsudon
where are we going here
i don't see it it's here maybe it's off
the menu
dude your favorite is so special
it's so special it's not on the menu
anymore all right whatever i'm going to
order it anyways
here we go katsudon
take a bite man happy birthday yeah
cheers bro
go ahead and try all right we're going
to eat and talk some business
i like it we're taking off jason
has a belly full of food and he's
feeling good he's going off on a rant
i am going what's your rant what's the
rant j rise my rant is that businesses
and entrepreneurs
don't understand the importance of
chicks like
just as a whole all across the world
like in all cultures like
chicks talk they gossip they spread the
word and they put a lot of emotion into
every story
so if they have a story about your
business i mean good or bad you will get
exposure and publicity chicks are
important if you have a t-shirt line
and you don't have sizes for chicks or
like
it doesn't fit their curves nicely
doesn't make them feel good like
you might as well shoot your clothing
line in the foot like it's over it's
done
i don't know that's it peace out he's
out
that's the rank for the day okay next
stop we're doing my favorite tradition
after having
some uh katsudon is to end up with uh
mcflurry oh awesome with some caramel
and oreos when your business was first
starting you would celebrate on
mcdonald's i did
okay we're gonna go in get some yummy
goodness
i got my uh oreo and caramel
cheers happy birthday cheers i can't eat
and film we'll just watch you eat then
okay we're pulling up to uh to my condo
for the next the next part of our
birthday adventure i finished my will
you finished are you finished
j rise has inhaled inhaled it's all gone
let's get inside the cup there gone left
man
gone he almost choked on it eating so
quick and talking stories i'm still uh
i'm working mine i'm nursing mine
but uh anyway okay in we go
evans condo follow our flow follow the
flow that's a good video man
there we go we came up to my condo
i had planned a nice surprise but uh we
got kicked out
we hit red tape we got we hit red tape
yeah bureaucracy we got kicked out of
the movie theater in my building
because you're not allowed to connect an
hdmi cable to it apparently it's too
rebel
because yeah because we're going to
break we're going to break their system
having hdmi cable hooked up to it
anyway so i don't want to get kicked out
of my condo so we're not going to
fight it but it's a pretty sweet setup
so what we're gonna do next
is watch the jay-z documentary oh
yes made in america amazing and we'll do
it on my
screen instead of our movie theater
downstairs here here's some water to
to quench that that uh
ice cream ice cream yeah i got some
snacks
we'll see if uh we're hungry for it
though so first up is uh
we got olive oil and sea salt
quinoa chips
cosmos creations caramel heavenly
morsels of baked corn
with all natural ingredients you can
pronounce ghirardelli
milk with caramel filling chocolate and
we've got some
sweet and sour filled twizzlers
it's filled with stuff okay let's let's
play
and see see what happens with this
document
based on my own experiences
credits are rolling we just finished
watching the jay-z
video made in america j rise
how are we feeling jay-z what's the
takeaway
the takeaway was you got to be yourself
and radiate that self
out to the world truth so like we gotta
i gotta show these pop chips
this is awesome i'm like yeah that's
pretty cool and italian
it says enjoy our products not fried not
baked
just popped pretty interesting and
delicious
and delicious okay let's go this is
going to be broadcast
we're giving you fame i didn't want to
follow you into the bathroom you know oh
dude
maybe you don't want that kind of fame
but bring out the paint
i like occasional moments of privacy all
jay all the time
channel yeah 24 hour game all the time
can you handle it believe
following j rides where we going man all
right good
press that down button oh yeah check it
out i'm in the camera too
why are we going to see what's on two i
don't know
i don't know my instinct said go to two
so we're following the flow
we're gonna check out the sauna i've
never used it
there it is we're going to turn it on
somehow
and sign it up i got you this cheers
there you go
brand new i got my own you feel it i'm
going to be taking hayden's
disney captain hook is this frozen towel
no no no no i'll take that you get the
little white one
slit anymore this is where we turn off
the camera
and uh enjoy some sauna
all right out of the sauna feeling
feeling good
feeling relaxed feeling chill all right
time to uh get some league on oh
dude are we doing league this is the
greatest birthday
ever
okay let's do some league ours this is a
ten hour song
we are in our seven right now almost
we're gonna play some league jason has
something to say
i do not encourage the 10 hour teemo
song i'm a fan
don't listen to jason on this one
finished up we won
captain teemo went three three uh three
kills three deaths twelve assists
and uh birthday boy mr ezreal
five kills two deaths five assists
and some game calling i'm feeling it
yeah a lot of game calls game calling
yeah but my morale is saved by the ec
belief
it's true it's dicey there for a while
it's true i was like ah
no cooperation saved
saved we had a full day
japanese feasting and mcflurry goodness
and quinoa chips and jay-z's made in
america
and sun sessions and league wins
for the win it's a good day
peace out happy birthday j rise are you
kidding me
i'm gorgeous they should just look at me
all day